impliquer les habitants pour préserver
le quartier valley bout de plaisir la
ville espère mettre fin aux dégradations
qui touchent déjà les 2 139 logements
réhabilités il y a un nom selon un
concept unique en ile de france des
fresques participative réalisé sur
plusieurs années par citécréation
spécialiste de l'art mural reconnu dans
le monde entier sédiments on pense avoir
trouvé une super idée qui est une idée
de remise en état en tout cas visuel de
ce quartier pour lui redonner une
identité par le biais de certains
artistes qui ont d'un grand talent et
qui depuis 35 ans agissant des quartiers
pas uniquement pour mettre des fresques
comme ça histoire de faire joli et pour
avoir tout un travail de fond avec les
habitants du quartier ces derniers
devront expliquer ce qui caractérise
leur quartier pour que la coopérative
d'artistes retranscrivent ses idées sur
les murs sous la forme de trompe l'oeil
saynètes aux couleurs vives ou
personnages emblématiques du quartier et
modification des comportements sur ces
liens sont très forts dans la mesure où
les gens sont fiers retrouve de la
dignité parce qu'on vient les voir si on
vient les voir ceux qui n'habitent pas
n'importe où et civils par n'importe où
ces îles sont pas n'importe qui et du
coup on remonte comme ça d'un cran et on
se redresse de quelques centimètres
certains sites deviennent même
incontournables comme le quartier bel
air de chartres on a évidemment cette
cathédrale qui magnifie que tout le
monde connaît mais le quartier bel-air
fait aussi partie maintenant des
endroits qu'on va visiter parce qu'on à
3500 mètres carrés de fresques qu'ils
sont qui sont qui sont pas vous avez la
boulangère qui est pas la petite fille
qui habite du car est du quartier qui
est peint sur le mur donc tout ça fait
partie sous les dunes contribution
totale des habitants à la réalisation de
ce projet et ils se sentent considérés
des fresques qui développe le tourisme
mais aussi des vocations
professionnelles puisque les jeunes
peuvent s'initier aux métiers porteurs
de peintres muralistes à plaisir le
bailleur social l'eau pied voix acté le
principe de la fresque le projet sera
défini en conseil d'administration au
mois d'avril restera ensuite à consulter
les quatre mille plaisirs wa concernés
il faut de temps il faut les
sensibiliser pour les montrer aussi les
vosges et comment comment on doit faire
qu'est ce que ça va donner la première
chose qu'ils vont poser des questions
sur les loyers aucune augmentation de
loyer n'est envisagée en attendant la
concrétisation du projet la deuxième
partie du chantier de réhabilitation du
vélib ou qui porte sur 450 logements
devrait être finalisée d'ici fin 2013